If your organization has determined that
data governance will play an important role,
you'll need to know who will be impacted
and what these people will need to do.
Data governance doesn't necessarily
have to incur a lot of overhead cost.
Generally, a big investment isn't required
in a whole bunch of new software tools.
Where most overhead is felt is with the
introduction of new responsibilities for
individuals. In large organizations this may
include hiring more and more dedicated staff.
This is not unusual, as governance,
risk, and compliance requirements of
many industries require specialized skills
and onerous reporting of deliverables.
Let's talk about one of the most common
mistakes organizations make with data.
It seems quite normal that we assign people to own
processes such as the Human Resources Director,
who's accountable for recruitment, or a Facilities
Manager, who is responsible for real estate needs.
But, when it comes to data, we often
don't assign owners to that data.
Organizations omit to give responsibility for
the maintenance of management of the data. It
seems intuitive that the Chief Financial Officer
should have responsibility for protecting credit
card information. Or the Sales Director should
ultimately own accurate monthly sales reports.
Let's be clear. Owning the data doesn't mean it
belongs to somebody. Ownership means being held
accountable for such things as data integrity,
security, and compliance requirements. We want
owners to really care about the data with which
they have been entrusted. Since data governance
is an enterprise concern, these data owners are
ultimately accountable to an authority that has an
enterprise perspective. With data flowing between
systems internally and externally, a single
data owner has insufficient visibility for an
enterprise role. For this, we need data stewards.
A data steward can be a single individual
or a team of people. The data steward is
the enterprise authority. It's the individual or
team ultimately responsible for data governance.
They create the rules and processes for governing
data and anticipate that data owners will follow
those rules and processes. Who are these
data stewards typically? They are existing
members of your organization. They might be
people, who, by the nature of their skills,
are well-suited to participating in a data
oversight capacity. Data stewards usually conduct
this role for just a few hours a month and spend
the rest of their time in their normal day jobs.
The data steward function is often
called the Data Governance Board,
the Data Stewardship Council, or the Data
Governance Office. In medium to large enterprises,
these groups are made up of several data stewards
that represent the entirety of the organization.
To maintain independence, data stewards are
typically different people than data owners.
The group's activities include agreeing on data
policy and procedures, resolving data challenges,
reviewing concerns, and making strategic
decisions regarding the good management
of data in the enterprise. Data stewards use
information provided by data owners and managers
and a wide range of stakeholders in order
to diligently conduct their work. The scope
of data owners and data stewards is an important
organizational decision and should be determined
in each organization based on such dependencies
as maturity, scale, and industry requirements.